for weeks Australia burnt and choking
smoke filled the air but this is dust a
huge dust storm rolled across the towns
of Dubbo and Parkes over the weekend
dramatic but not dangerous and elsewhere
it's now flooding in Melbourne
torrential rain storms and hailstones
the size of golf balls qualifying
matches at the Australian Open were
abandoned smoke from bush fires had been
a big worry for players now it's further
rain interruptions this tournament that
that obviously you know would have a
lots of troubles if they have to cancel
matches and you know luckily they have
three closed you know courts with with
the roof but still there's so many
matches so many players so let's hope
that the worst is behind us the rain has
also been heavy in parts of the states
of Queensland and New South Wales for
those tackling the bush fires it's just
what was needed though dozens of fires
are still burning the water has dampened
them and none are threatening homes or
lives but the economic impact of the
fires is still being felt tourism in
summer is usually the backbone of
Kangaroo Island's economy but this
cruise ship is the first to visit the
island of Australia's south coast since
fires earlier this month most tourists
are staying away they think their whole
islands on fire and it's not so we
really need to send that message out
that the islands are still accessible
Australia is huge varied weather is
normal but the start of 2020 has been
exceptional Andrew Thomas
al Jazeera Sydney